bienvenidos a reporteros el documental
comenzamos uno de los hechos más tristes
de la historia universal ha sido sin
duda el genocidio de ruanda en 1994 unas
800.000 personas fueron asesinadas en
sólo tres meses la mayoría de las
víctimas fueron tutsis masacrados por
los hurtos y los pocos autos que se
resistían también eran ejecutados otros
de esta etnia decidieron arriesgarse y
ayudar a los tutsis quienes fueron estas
personas porque tomaron la decisión de
ayudar y como lo hicieron en el
siguiente reportaje conoceremos a esos
hombres y mujeres que fueron olvidados
por la historia pero que mostraron una
profunda humanidad durante los 100 días
que duró este genocidio
[Música]
no no
a
un país con colinas paradisíacas que se
sumió en la barbarie
unos habitantes de apariencia tranquila
que se convirtieron en asesinos
en 1994 ruanda cayó en una locura mortal
fueron pocos los que se opusieron
[Música]
y se corta se recorta se mutila las
personas
los cadáveres cubren el suelo pueden ver
que todavía hay algunos con rastros de
vida en la calle porque no han muerto
del todo es una carnicería es
sencillamente un matadero
en tan sólo tres meses más de 800.000
ruandeses principalmente tutsis fueron
exterminados por la mayoría futura
los pocos puntos que trataron de
resistirse fueron ejecutados
sin embargo algunos no siguieron a la
manada entre ellos
broadwalk obrero agrícola
[Música]
era como sacrificarse al entrar en una
casa en llamas para salvar a alguien del
incendio
[Música]
damas director de un orfanato incluso si
es con días así fuera un bebé tutsi y te
descubrían te mataban junto con toda su
familia y josephine propietaria de un
bar yo tenía claro que las personas que
mandaban eran seres humanos personas
inocentes yo escogí a ayudarlos con la
fuerza de dios y si me atrapaban con
ellos nos iríamos juntos
porque tomaron esa decisión cómo lo
hicieron
esta es la historia de estos tres justos
y de las personas que salvaron
[Música]
tomás es un sobreviviente del genocidio
en esa época yo tenía 10 años y al igual
que todas las personas a mi alrededor
tenía miedo en abril de 1994
este joven tutsi llegó a pasar
vacaciones en la casa del campo de su
tipo en kibuye
a orillas del lago kivú cuando se
cometieron los primeros asesinatos el
prefecto le pidió a los tutsis que se
agruparán en lugares seguros para
garantizar su seguridad
algunas personas se refugiaron en la
iglesia sobre todo los cristianos como
la familia de mi tío pensaban que más
valía morir en la casa de dios y en
vista de otros fueron al estadio como
les recomendaron las autoridades para
aprovecharlo mejor pero en realidad era
una trampa para agruparlos y aniquilar
los más rápidos con armas pesadas
[Música]
el prefecto le dio la orden de los
militares a las milicias e incluso a los
habitantes del común y asesinar a los
tutsis josephine es u2 esta propietaria
de un bar casada y madre de siete niños
asistiría la masacre de más de diez mil
tutsis
luego de que hubiese una curva masas
ánima cristal
escuchamos el resto de las armas
proveniente del estadio ubicado justo
detrás
oíamos los gritos elevarse a nuestro
alrededor sacaron a muchas personas en
el estadio luego fueron a matar en la
iglesia los que pudieron huyeron a
esconderse entre los arbustos
fueron perseguidos y asesinados otros
murieron hasta en el lago
y los asesinos eran entusiastas estaban
motivados era como si hubiesen
encontrado algo bueno en las matanzas
estaban equipados para eso estaban
listos para todo ya no eran humanos se
habían convertido en llenas
el tío de tomás y su familia reunidos en
la iglesia murieron pero el joven que se
había quedado en la casa de campo se
salvó de la masacre y se escondió con el
fin de evitar las bandas de asesinos que
perseguían a los sobrevivientes
[Música]
alejaré vitoreados en breve dormía y en
medio de estos arbustos buscaba el mejor
lugar pensé que si me dirigía hacia ese
gran matorral allá arriba tendría más
posibilidades de sobrevivir si fuera un
día más
me moví por toda esta zona que viene
aquí estaba completamente desesperado
nadie
estaba muy mal era difícil reconocer que
era un ser humano tenía los ojos
maltrechos estaba completamente
desorientado su ropa estaba hecha
pedazos en pocas palabras no era
agradable de ver
y no
si las personas te ven te van a matar
sal de ahí y ven conmigo
una mujer salió de su casa y me vio allá
arriba
me llamó y yo pensé que no tenía nada
más que perder
incluso aunque corriera el riesgo de
morir era mejor ir allá
estrella más enfadó muchísimo
[Música]
con agua
en el día con él
[Música]
era una infracción muy grave si escondía
asuntos y te daban la orden de matarlo y
luego te mataban a ti mis ojos no
estábamos advertidos era como una ley
todo el mundo lo sabía
chari jaime se le habían explicado a los
campesinos de hecho es por eso que
muchas personas no se atrevieron a
esconder a sus amigos
porque era una misión imposible
era como un sacrificio
[Música]
josephine al igual que todos los
ruandeses vacunada desde la infancia por
la propaganda gubernamental en la
escuela en la radio en los periódicos se
repetía que un día sería necesario
deshacerse de todos los tutsis estos
últimos eran apodados las cucarachas y
ngenzi en ruandés
[Música]
queridos oyentes buen día tienen están
oyendo rtlm los estamos encaminando
hacia un día en el que diremos que no
hay un solo enzimas en el país
seleccionado un posible que eso sólo
será posible si continuamos nuestro
impulso de exterminarlos
[Música]
estruch si sabía que se había convertido
en una presa así que buscó refugio en su
oficina en la agencia forestal de kibuye
con la esperanza de que las milicias no
se atrevieron a ir a matarlo ahí porque
son los suizos quienes gestionan ese
organismo
y escuchar a las personas derribar las
puertas y subir al edificio civil donde
mi mejor amigo se había escondido con su
familia
así que derribaron las puertas y los
sacaron y los mataron
me trastorno muchos perdí la razón
decidí irme me dirigí a la colina y
después me encontré con josephine ella
era una vecina no era realmente una
amiga yo sabía que era youtube
en shanghái quiere ahora la clase
encontré a pierre aturdido y le dije
bien qué haces ahí ve muy bien lo que
está pasando
lo que quería era dinero él me contestó
no tengo otra opción no sé a dónde iba
entonces le dije ven a mi casa cruza los
campos de maíz y de habichuela
dv desde que ella me miró me dio
esperanza
pierre se refugió en su casa en total 12
personas pasarían por ahí sólo unos
cuantos días nunca más que eso que las
milicias registraban de manera
permanente los domicilios una belleza no
fui a buscarlos para salvarlos ellos
vinieron a mí salían de la selva
transitaban sin ser vistos me mandan
jasen tengo fornarini como habría podido
dejarlos afuera imposible
no hubo nada
era una fuerza que me llegaba desde dios
nada más yo tenía claro que las personas
que mataban eran seres humanos personas
inocentes en manera de envases a fuga ni
yo ni me van gogh yo escogí a ayudarlos
con la fuerza de dios si me atrapaban
con ellos nos iríamos juntos
josephine de tendió la mano cada taxi
que el destino puso en su camino algunos
fueron aún más lejos provocando ese
destino y yendo a buscar tutsis por su
cuenta para salvarlos
a unos 50 kilómetros al este de kibuye
se encuentra chino wei es un pueblo
típico del campo ruandés ubicado en un
paisaje de colinas y de campos
fred ward es un modesto obrero agrícola
el que mataba estaba feliz se gastaba de
haber matado a muchas personas y estaba
orgulloso de esos los contaba en todas
partes no tenía ningún remordimiento
desde aragón divisible bajo coco narong
hormigón algunos incluso obligaron a un
hombre a tomar a su mujer en público y
luego les cortaron la cabeza
[Música]
y no había nada que hacer
ni tanga
sino en un juego era como sacrificarse
al entrar en una casa en llamas para
salvar a alguien del incendio
al y magia
[Música]
como muchos otros tutsis antonio se
refugió en su pueblo natal para buscar
protección entre su familia y amigos
pero el genocidio también golpeó y walk
away
nos fuimos rápido de la casa ni siquiera
la cerramos nos fuimos así nada más el
ambiente era el miedo nos preguntábamos
qué pasaría después todo el mundo veía
la muerte en frente suyo
[Música]
antonio mucho a la parroquia anglicana y
fue precisamente ahí donde fraud llegó a
buscar tutsis pero como hizo para
salvarlos
este wood y le sacaría provecho a toda
su experiencia como campesinos
adiós se me ocurrió la idea del hueco
mientras oía radio escuché que los
soldados cavan huecos y que se quedaban
ahí
así que por qué no acabar un hueco y
utilizarlo para salvar gente entonces
construyen huecos como una casa con una
pequeña apertura para entrar te lo cubrí
de ramas y de sierra y luego no siempre
por encima
y fue así como produjo escondió a 19
personas de la uned y era aquí estábamos
juntos los niños las niñas y las mujeres
estábamos muy apretados nos acostábamos
hasta la salida del monte y cuando
queríamos cambiar nos poníamos de lado
así contábamos y 123 y luego todo el
mundo lo hacía al mismo tiempo pasábamos
días así llovía entraba agua poníamos
las manos así para tener agua para beber
y luego bebíamos entraban a los huecos
entre 3 y 4 de la mañana y sólo salían
en la noche - cuando las milicias
estaban en los alrededores
prefirió ponernos muy cerca del camino
para no levantar sospechas no hacíamos
ruido nos hablábamos muy bajitos muy
valientes pensábamos que si algún día
vendrían o si sabían quiénes éramos ese
sería el fin
dios solo dios nos protegía era
desesperante pacientes de expertos en
web
portugal tuvo dos semanas para pensar
antes de que comenzaran las matanzas
en kigali el genocidio empezó la noche
del 6 de abril
[Música]
bien
miles de tutsis buscaban refugio pero
adónde ir
este orfanato acogía en esa época 65
niños y su director damas y simba en
youtube
él vio enfrentar la afluencia de decenas
de familias tutsis
todos esperaban que las milicias no se
atrevieron a matar en su orfanato
al principio me enviaron los niños
yo no podía rechazar a los niños es
difícil y luego cuando se volvió muy
difícil los adultos también empezaron a
llegar y yo no podía echarlos porque ya
tenía a sus hijos
como le voy a decir a una madre no entre
salgan y salvar a su hijo además ella
estaba huyendo de la muerte él fue el
amor
así
damas se para de inmediato a los niños
de los adultos sitúa los más jóvenes con
los huérfanos
y los niños estaban con los demás aquí
en los dormitorios pero había escondido
a los padres aquí adentro es una
enfermería
nos poníamos allá adentro era un baño
entonces había cinco personas aquí
estaban todos de pie a sido apretados
apretados
poníamos la puerta así y poníamos esto
así y eso escondía las puertas las
milicias no sabían que había personas
adentro y cuando veían que estaba
abierto no les impedía mos entrar e
inspeccionar y hacer todo lo que
quisieran ellos miraban y decían bueno
está bien
en 1994 primo gabo era un joven lobo de
la política tutsi o fundador del partido
de oposición estaba ante los primeros de
la lista de personas por ejecutar el
también corrió el orfanato con su mujer
y sus niños
honestamente no pensé que fuera a
sobrevivir porque porque cada día
recibimos información es esta persona
murió esta persona fue asesinada aquella
otra persona fue asesinada imagínense
pasar prácticamente tres meses en los
baños deberíamos hablar muy fácil no
podíamos mirar por la ventana era una
situación muy estresante
[Música]
en la noche salían para ir a comer algo
estirarse un poco y hablar un rato pero
primero yo debía inspeccionar el lugar
para ver si todo estaba tranquilo porque
a veces las milicias me rodeaban un poco
por todas partes
durante los tres meses del genocidio las
milicias ayudadas por la población
sembraron el terror en toda la capital
incluyendo delante del orfanato
y se ha de invertir aquí había una
barrera de milicias entonces ellos
detenían a todas las personas les pedían
la identificación
ahí estaba indicada la etnia y cuando
alguien era tutsi los llevaban a la fosa
común allá lo mataban allá lo tiraban
allá adentro
al principio damas se congració con los
jefes de las milicias con dinero y luego
con comida y cuando no tuvo nada más que
ofrecer y las milicias empezaron a
sospechar trato de razonar con ellos
[Música]
estaban buscando tutsis y yo les
explicaba escuchen estos son mis niños
huérfanos y pienso que entre ellos
pueden estar los suyos porque yo no sé
distinguir un niño tóxico de un tutú si
matan a los niños y mañana se dan cuenta
de que estaban sus propios primos entre
esos niños no tendrían remordimientos
entonces eran los niños los que
protegían a los adultos eso es lo que yo
diría
pero para que esta estrategia funcionara
jamás le hizo creer a los niños tutsis
que sus padres habían ido a esconderse a
otra parte
[Música]
los niños no sabían que había adultos
porque un niño es un niño es inocente
un miliciano puede preguntarle tú estás
aquí pero dónde están tus padres y un
niño indicaría de inmediato están ahí
bento entonces le oculta vamos a los
niños donde estaban sus padres
y
ah
[Música]
hacía meses no veíamos a nuestros hijos
entonces hicimos un pequeño hueco y
tratábamos de mirar por el hueco para
ver cómo estaban los niños
era algo terrible disculpen me pongo un
poco cuando hablo siento muchas
emociones
es terrible
y si vamos
pero señor mina tras echar porque
esconder engañar mentir todos los medios
sirven para salvar vidas
ah
[Música]
el memorial de entrar a amando muy lejos
de kigali fue construido aquí en memoria
de los tres mil tutsis que fueron
masacrados en la iglesia local
[Música]
el profesor calle y chema delante del
muro de nombres de las víctimas en 2009
coordinó el único estudio universitario
sobre los justos ahí se encuentra en 270
y por falta de medios sólo se llevó a
cabo sobre una décima parte del
territorio ruandés un nuestro don
paterno aun cuando sean toca su desdén s
persona no encontrábamos un término al
menos en español para designar a esas
personas que habían salvado a los demás
y tomamos prestado el término de los
justos de la última guerra mundial
relacionado con los sobrevivientes
judíos que fueron salvados por
benefactores y fueron llamados los
justos de las naciones
73 crisis allí
y crear los justos y puede sonar un poco
triste son personas sencillas del campo
que no tienen mucha educación ese es en
realidad el perfil típico porque
intelectuales que habían hecho muchos
estudios hay realmente muy pocos blancos
sí
son personas que no se distinguen mucho
de sus vecinos pero en el momento
crucial aceptaron tomar una decisión que
podía constituir un riesgo enorme esas
personas se comportan exactamente de
manera opuesta a la locura colectiva y
entonces son personas que representan un
modelo para la humanidad
bien
no no
[Música]
en 1994 gradual el obrero agrícola que
escondía tutsis en un hueco era padre de
cinco niños y su mujer estaba embarazada
con el sexto
[Música]
para sanz un libro vaya a la estricta
hidrata tu balance de abarán factor
inhibidor un drama sigue un día tres
soldados vinieron aquí sospechaban de mí
requisaron toda la casa por supuesto no
encontraron a nadie porque las personas
estaban en los huecos entonces me
hicieron salir y pensé que me iban a
matar pero hablaron y uno de ellos dijo
buscamos en todas partes y no
encontramos nada
francamente realmente piensan que este
tipo puede estar escondiendo gente y
además alimentando la y me dejaron ir
es un don personal es difícil explicar
por qué hice eso a veces me aislaba para
pensar lo que pasaría si me atrapaban me
decía bueno si me atrapan voy a morir
con estas personas pero son seres
humanos igual que yo así que estaba
listo para morir con ellos
en el cual ya no tocaban
[Música]
miriam amo me ponga horas
aquí nace bujanda hijo de btt que vive
en quilá o flores mujer de canjet
bandera verde y también los jóvenes del
sector digital más precisamente en la
área de roxy music
nombres de personas por ejecutar eran
difundidos por la radio de todo el país
después de las masacres en masa siguió
la cacería de cada individuo
[Música]
a las orillas del lago kivú que bulle es
la región con más tutsis la población
incansable los rastreaban sin parar
para josep team la propietaria del bar
era impensable mantener mucho tiempo en
su casa los fugitivos
[Música]
jan wijn en boca con orgullo por ojo que
formó los tutsis no tenían casi ninguna
posibilidad de lograrlo porque no
solamente tenían a los militares detrás
también tenían a la población
cada uno estaba convencido de que los
taxis eran su enemigo personal entonces
como podían salir librados en ruanda no
había un lugar para esconderse
entonces me robé un barco para enviarlos
hacia la isla de juegos y ya estarían a
salvo kibuye está sobre la orilla
ruandesa del lago kivú a 40 kilómetros
de allí en todo el centro del lago
esta es la isla de edwin en la república
democrática del congo llegará hasta ya
significaba escapar del genocidio
pierre el funcionario de la agencia
forestal fue el primero en hacer esta
peligrosa travesía remando
we left despres around
nos fuimos de ese lugar hacia las 8 de
la noche como ven pasar por ahí era el
camino más corto pero en esta isla sobre
la costa ruandesa había muchos
milicianos entonces nos fuimos por este
lado y llegamos al congo kuwait week a
las 4 y 45 de la mañana
five
[Música]
la opsis live
osama live arts on the heights a todo el
mundo le gusta vivir
y me siento feliz porque estoy vivo pero
por otro lado me siento mal por las
personas que perdieron su vida sin razón
and sometimes dice
dejamos y a veces es difícil contar esta
historia es una red sin historia
es
el escape funcionó
de ahí en adelante yo se piense las
ingeniería para obtener nuevas
embarcaciones gracias a su recursividad
otras 10 personas lograrían al igual que
pierde llegar hasta la isla de id
[Música]
pero para tomas de 10 años en esa época
era imposible hacer solo la travesía de
noche remando casi 10 horas
así que josephine lo llevó a su pueblo
natal un poco más lejos a orillas del
lago
[Música]
me sentía mejor donde yo sé pero en su
casa
dada la situación que había fuera tal
vez quiera ya era mejor que quedarse que
era un niño obedecía le dije nadie te
matará mientras estemos juntos y si nos
encontramos con alguien yo soy la que da
explicaciones pero yo también pensaba si
se dan cuenta que estamos subiendo nos
matarán tenía miedo pero no tenía otra
opción
[Música]
y ella me dijo voy a llevarte con mi
familia son buenos no tendrás que
esconderte y hasta podrás jugar con los
otros niños de la casa
[Música]
nos dieron un gran sueño dice youtube si
les dije este niño de padres y de madres
humanas vamos si quieren ir a ya salvo
algunos que se fueron embargo allí y
cualquiera que vamos llegarán ira
les confió este niño pero vendría
después a buscarlo porque todo el resto
de su familia fue asesinada aceptaron
quedarse con él
estoy realmente orgullosa de mi hija
realmente orgullosa de mi hermana menor
también estabais de newry de le dije
déjalo jugar
ocuparse de las vacas porque aquí no lo
conocen y sobre todo no lo deje salir
solos no lo escondan les agradezco desde
el fondo de mi corazón que sean
bendecidos por todo lo que hicieron
y que le transmitan a sus hijos esa
valentía para que en el futuro sigan su
ejemplo
james
las misiones también
sí
[Música]
y
miren a poco
una vez de regreso a su casa josephine
continuó su misión de rescate eso le
significó rozar la muerte
durante los últimos días del genocidio
una mujer y su bebé llegarán a buscar
refugio en su casa pero un guardia los
vio y los siguió
[Música]
abrir un fallo no tomar agua
le dijo a la mujer ven aquí ella se
levantó y le dijo que se hiciera a un
lado y yo me acosté en el piso boca
abajo y perdí la razón me vi muerta y
kumba y ahí escuché unos tiros dos o
tres no más
la mujer dijo ay me dieron y no volví a
decir nunca nada más
ése había sido sus tiempos
josephine le dijo al guardia que no
sabía nada de esa mujer él le creyó y la
dejó ir
[Música]
en kigali el director del orfanato damas
también viviría momentos escalofriantes
[Música]
del plafón la oficina aunque 7 bits
o en el techo de la cocina había 81
salió para hacer sus necesidades no lo
vieron y lo atraparon fueron
inmediatamente a la cocina al techo y
bajaron a todas las personas que estaban
adentro familia entre los ocho estaba el
sobrino de pee que sabía muy bien que su
mujer estaba en la casa grande aquí sí
que su tío y sus hijos que estaban aquí
así que pensó bueno se acabó mata nos
torturaron hasta la madrugada
y no dijeron nada fueron como nuestros
martes decidió porque sí confesaban todo
el mundo caía entonces en ese momento
fue cuando decidí ir a buscar ayuda real
eso sé
la salvación vendría de los altos mandos
extranjeros informados sobre el riesgo
de una masacre en el orfanato
presionaron al gobierno para evitar el
baño de sangre unos días después las
masacres terminaron
salve 325 niños y 80 adultos como en
total sumaban 405 personas y una de las
personas confiaron en mí y vinieron a mí
así que no podía ser ruin y decirles no
no no no entre a alguien que estaba
pidiendo auxilio
el amor que supone de gonzález era
enviarlos de regreso a la boca del lobo
no era humano y yo mismo pensé que no
escaparía porque la muerte rondaba por
ahí y pensé si mañana es mi turno que le
diría al buen dios más vale morir como
hombre que morir siendo ruin y abandonar
a las personas que están en peligro
entonces en kigali damas salvo cientos
de tutsis en software gracias a sus
huecos fred ward protegió la vida de 19
personas
y en kibuye joseph y le permitió a 11
tutsis huir al congo en barco y mantuvo
seguro al joven thomas solo queda una
pregunta de dónde sacaron los justos esa
fuerza que les permitió resistir parada
más se trata casi un deber familiar su
abuelo fundó el orfanato su hijo recibió
la antorcha y a su vez sedujo a damas
bajo la consigna de proteger siempre a
los más vulnerables
[Música]
y salvar a las personas que acudieron a
mí pero para mí es por la educación de
mis padres me enseñaron siempre el amor
me enseñaron a amar al otro como a uno
mismo
[Música]
josephine muy creyente también siguió el
ejemplo de su madre veinte años atrás su
madre le había tendido la mano a los
tutsis perseguidos
[Música]
hubo una familia que mis padres ayudaron
cuando quemaron su casa vivían del otro
lado del río vinieron a poner a salvo
sus pertenencias en nuestra casa en 1973
pero en esa época no hubo muchos muertos
se llamaban a mí nada aguantado
hoy en día los ruandeses conocen el
papel de los justos
[Música]
en la capital en el memorial de guisos y
donde están sepultados los restos de más
de 250.000 tutsis hay una sala entera
dedicada a ellos
la foto de fruto y su historia están
exhibidas
[Música]
al salir del genocidio estos salvadores
a menudo eran maltratados eran traidores
para los untos siempre sospechosos para
los tutsis sería necesario esperar
varios años antes de que la sociedad lo
reconociera por lo que son
[Música]
repente danza de convicción
ap/youtube esté convencido un poco de
que casi todos los junto habían sido
verdugos de alguna manera cosas guapas
[Música]
bien fuera por el uso del machete o por
el de la denuncia
cuando realizamos este estudio nos dimos
cuenta de que había bastante más
personas altruistas en las que no
habíamos pensado antes con un avión 11
[Música]
a veces mis hijos me preguntan porque ya
no tienes padres de tus abuelos y los
demás
les decimos que es a causa del genocidio
pero si lo dejamos ahí diciendo que los
justos mataron a los tutsis a causa de
políticas olvidamos de que fue un
holding quien me salgo así es la vida
life and now dueño y ahora cuando se
encuentra con josep ineficiente hay
sirvamos mishima esencias su manera me
siento como alguien que se encuentra con
su salvador humanamente es mi salvador a
ustedes mismos pueden entenderlo
sentirlo si vuelven a ver a la persona
que le salvó la vida si me siento en las
nubes
lo único que no se puede reemplazar es
la mamá pero josephine es para mí como
una mamá como un modelo ella me ayuda y
ella me da consejos cuando lo necesito
realmente me vuelve a dar confianza en
mí mismo
motivo
y a uno de los que salve me dio una vaca
una vaca muy linda y atestiguó delante
de todo el mundo cómo es de bueno
recompensar a las personas que han hecho
el bien nada vale más que la generosidad
es un gusto es alguien que piensa en los
demás antes en sí mismo es un justo hoy
en día cuando pienso en lo que pasó me
digo a pesar de todo honre a mis padres
allí donde estén de cualquier manera
están orgullosos
[Música]
realmente no sé cómo calificar a este
hombre pero es un héroe para nosotros
todo el mundo sabe que si aún no lo
atrapaban con alguien que uno había
escondido era hombre muerto pero él
superó todo eso hay que cantar eso su
heroísmo porque desde el principio es la
única persona que ve y dedicarse sí no
han jugado hay un móvil cuando algo es
bueno hay que hablar sobre eso
así la persona que escuchó podrá hacer
lo mismo seguir el ejemplo
[Música]
hay que mostrar las buenas acciones en
todas partes
esteban buch y si no soy yo quien las
cuenta otros lo harán que las personas
aprecian o no lo que hice lo más
importante es que se cuenta encima hay
muchísimo de hecho por eso están ustedes
aquí para mostrar mi testimonio
[Música]
gracias por acompañarnos en esta emisión
de reporteros el documental que puede
ingresar a nuestra página web france24
puntocom para ver esta edición y las
satélites hasta la próxima semana
[Música]